in this capsule we will describe
and motivated the concept of local search
then the purpose of this part of
course it's first of all good
understand what is the difference
between heuristic research and the
local search then from his going to see
three methods to make the
local search
the first one that's going to be the method of
cambi the second sim in the late evening or
annealing simulate in French and finally
we will talk about them the algorithms
genetic
so let's start with quick lapidot of
skiing and the context of research
heuristic and among others of
the star algorithm that we saw
previously
so in this case also when doing
heuristic search in a graph
one of them is a function aim
goal that allows us to identify if a
node n is an ubu a place that one
wants to reach a particular
peculiarity of the problem is
that in fact the solution that we
interest it's really a way
initial data up to a final or
an oversight is also ideally
wants to have a path that is optimal the
shortest way and in the
research process but we have to
among other things store all of
nodes that are who are encountered that
are visited in order, among other
to ensure that we do not revisit
nutrients on the other hand for some
problems actually we'll see in
this part is part of the coup we have
certain characteristics that makes that
the algorithm to the stars and not
necessarily appropriate so sometimes
we will see among other things a relationship
of an objective function that one
wants to optimize either maximize or
minimized maybe we'll have more
a goal function that will allow us
to identify when one has reached a
solution as it may possibly we
interested in in some problems
it's to make optimizing a certain
function that we took function objectives
who will identify us just how much a
does not correspond to a good good state
solution or if sometimes we will the solution
which is going to be searched is only
precisely the identification of this node
which is optimal according to our function of
goals or a whole that is close
an optimal solution but we will not
look at the path that allows us
to get to this draw is finally there
some problems but over space
states or nudes that we explored will
to be too big to allow us
to register them so visit us
it's for this kind of problem there that
the local search is going to be
particularly appropriate an example
of a problem like that is the problem
of solving the enigma of the que queens
or enter into this riddle we must
place a number of reindeers on
a chessboard that will contain a large g
and n colleges and we have to place all cn
reindeer there so that does not exist
reindeer that attack each other
in other words we must not have two
queens that lies on the same
diagonal the same column where the same
row
so you have an example in what 6
where n is equal to 8 or effective to
check
none of the queens who are attacking
mutually that is on the same
row where the town hall like this is a
solution to this enigma the the dance that
if in fact we are really interested
simply to a place that corresponds to
this configuration of 8 reindeer that
does not attack the objective function that
will be made the name of reindeer who
tackle this is an example of
objective functions for this problem there
and finally we are just interested in un
which optimizes 7 works the most
possible therefore that a number of annuities
tackle as little as possible to
know in this case 6.0 so the way
to get there and not really
important since just know the
let us know how
organize the ranks
so this type of problem there research
local is going to be an appropriate solution
a peculiarity looking for the 15
is that the local market will keep
only a number number
limited of honor in memory the case the
simpler that is first case that we are going
to see is that of a city like bing
where we will keep only one in memory at
as we search
that we run the algorithm is in
more elaborate hulls in order one
night set among others with the
genetic algorithms
we will keep an eye we see a
all of us that we will call
population then this population there this
set of new routes evolve to
as the gateway goes
run
so as I said sometimes way
general research algae
local authorities will try to optimize
objective function that is specified by
the user in in the frame hill
climbing is this function that goes
determine which node to visit
next as we will see
and actually in the algorithms
genetic this goal function the
will allow me to design and a
fitness or adaptation function that
will intervene in the calculation that will us
to identify what is the
next generation the next
together not to generate in
dalger execution is the most
important to remember in relation to
local search algorithms this is
that it does not guarantee that we are going
find a solution that gets so
his atrix is ​​really it's especially at
we will be able to find
a solution that is acceptable in a
deadline that is going to be that they are going to be
interesting that will be fast